today on the matt well show the super
bowl last night was one long parade of
leftist hypocrisy we'll count the ways
today also we'll review some of the
weird and woke commercials that
companies spent millions of dollars to
air during the broadcast plus nancy
pelosi officially slams the door shut on
the defund the police movement and joe
biden speaks out against racism in the
nfl at least i think that's what he was
doing it's hard to tell anymore in our
daily cancellation we'll deal with the
latest leftist innovation it's called
platonic conscious co-parenting all of
that and more today on the matt wall
show
[Music]
constant contact is a digital marketing
platform that helps small businesses and
non-profits of all sizes build grow and
succeed with email marketing contact
management industry leading list growth
tools social media ads and more constant
contact helps small businesses connect
with customers find new ones and sell
online all for one easy to use platform
they've been trusted by millions of
businesses to help improve their
marketing with a 97 deliver
deliverability rate you can rest assured
that your customers and potential
customers are getting the right message
at the right time with a simple
interface constant contacts easy to use
platform makes contact management easier
than ever their list growth tools help
you find a bigger audience fast lead
generation landing pages
text to join in social media ads are
proven to grow your list and drive
engagement with your brand with
thousands of integrations you can sync
constant contacts tools with the tools
you're already using powerful automation
tools help you send the right message to
the right person at the right time every
time to start your free digital
marketing trial today visit
constantcontact.com
so last night was the super bowl as you
may have heard it was a game between the
cincinnati bengals a team with no fans
at all outside of cincinnati and the los
angeles rams a team with no fans at all
anywhere outside los angeles or inside
ultimately the rams prevailed marking
the first nfl championship for a third
world country which i thought was was
was really nice truly it was inspiring
to see that even if la can't stop gangs
of hoodlums from ransacking stores and
committing violent crimes or you know
prevent prevented sidewalks from
becoming homeless refugee camps or clean
up the trash that covers literally every
square inch of that putrid and hideous
city
it can at least score enough points to
beat the bengals
as it happens the super bowl was
actually played in los angeles this year
requiring an impressive effort by the
city to clean up enough of the garbage
and use needles so that fans had space
to park their cars at least however
some people think that it isn't fair
that you know one of the teams competing
in the game got to host the game as well
and i agree that it isn't fair there
shouldn't be any more home super bowls
which is why i think every super bowl
should be hosted in dc or dallas from
here on out because that way this will
never happen again but in any case it
was a good game i must admit it was it
was also along with being a good game
a festival of rank hypocrisy
by the left now remember of course that
hypocrisy does not simply mean
doing one thing while saying another
that might not be hypocrisy at all that
might be simple cowardice or
inconsistency
hypocrisy is pretending to believe
things that you don't actually believe
and hypocrisy is endemic in our culture
which is a problem because it's
impossible to have meaningful debates or
come to any sort of understanding
between sides if so many of the people
involved in the conversation don't
actually believe anything that they're
saying
now if you've noticed that our debates
are almost always fruitless
and nobody is listening to anybody and
nothing comes of any of it
this is why
lots of people don't believe what
they're saying they don't believe much
of anything at all i think
which brings us back to the super bowl
the biggest entertainment event of the
year an occasion for all of the
country's biggest corporations to spend
millions of dollars to make themselves
visible because they weren't visible
enough already while also parading their
wokeness around for the acceptance and
approval of the sorts of people who
pretend to be rebels against the system
that caters to their every emotional
whim
now it began with an in unexpectedly
respectful and well-executed national
anthem performance
something the nfl can get away with
because you know they have to get away
with doing a respectful national anthem
these days but they can get right with
it because they also make sure to
include the so-called black national
anthem in the broadcast we are a country
if you hadn't heard by now with two
national anthems
the original written by francis scott
key and then this other thing called
lift every voice and sing
the nfl must lay these sacrifices upon
the altar of wokeness so that the left
won't accuse it of racism because of
course an organization in which 60
percent of its athletes and the majority
of its most visible stars are black
has to constantly prove that it's not
racist
and the efforts are all in vain as
always
no matter what the nfl does it will
always be labeled racist because that's
how the game is played
the left derives much of its political
power from the phantom of racism they
will not let that phantom go no matter
how desperate and absurd the racism
claims have to be
speaking of which just as a side note
brian flores a story that we've been
tracking on this show he's the former
nfl head coach who's now suing the
league for systemic racism
just yesterday
before the super bowl he added the
houston texans to his lawsuit now he
alleges that the texans failed to hire
him because of their racism
the inconvenient detail here is that the
texans didn't hire him
because they wanted someone else
who is also black
they hired a black head coach
but it was the wrong black head coach
and so they're still racist
once again this is how the game is
played
but uh to the black national anthem uh
the the well yeah the not the national
anthem but the fake one the black
national anthem if you thought the idea
of a racially tribalized national anthem
couldn't get any more grotesque
wait until you see what it looked like
when they performed it watch
[Applause]
[Music]
sing
a
song
full of the faith that the dark past
[Music]
does any other country in existence have
this by the way
before now lots of countries almost
every country before some big event
they're going to sing a national anthem
does any other country have two
you know if they've got the normal one
and then another one for a specific
racial group
but the singers there they were
performing with the accompaniment of the
la youth orchestra
now as you can see if you're if you're
watching on the the video podcast
the lead adult performers didn't have
masks on
the kids in the background did
there's something distinctly creepy and
dystopian about the sight of two adults
standing in front of a group of masked
faceless children
and it's a site we've gotten used to of
course that's also a site that isn't
going away anytime soon in fact los
angeles along with other big liberal
cities across the country
they've begun to relax their mask
mandates for everyone except school
children
the people who least need the masks and
who suffer the most psychologically and
developmentally from wearing them
are the people who'll be forced to
continue wearing them while everyone
else gets to take them off
at the game last night there was not
even an attempt by any of the leftist
luminaries in attendance to pretend that
they take masking seriously just watch
the announcers go through the litany of
celebrities in attendance and notice
what accessory is missing from all of
these people watch
we're in hollywood what do we got here
we've got jay-z
matt damon
here
[Music]
lebron
jennifer and ben
yeah smith
there you go there's my kind of
celebrity yeah now we're talking i mean
where else will they be
not a mask in sight all of them maskless
lebron james is wearing an entire
diamond mine around his neck but uh he
left the mask at home priorities i
suppose
and yet even as lebron and jennifer
lopez and ben affleck and all the rest
of them and matt damon
um and the mayor of los angeles all
partied at the super bowl in a crowd of
75 000 revelers all without masks
children in the city are currently
sitting in classrooms fully masked
a festival of hypocrisy like i said
and we haven't even made it to the
halftime show
halftime sponsored by the aarp featured
dr dre snoop dogg eminem and 50 cent and
also mary j blige because they they knew
they had to throw a woman in there for
appearances sake but all these men are
in their 40s and 50s all were wheeled
out of their retirement homes to perform
their hit songs from back when they were
relevant and to embarrass millennials
with children like myself by forcing us
to admit to our kids that we used to
listen to this kind of stuff
the timing of this performance was
interesting though
because here are dr dre snoop dogg
eminem
on the biggest entertainment platform in
the world
performing to universal acclaim and
adulation
this is happening after three weeks of
the left insisting that joe rogan
shouldn't have a platform anymore
because he said bad words a long time
ago
some might point out
that dr dre snoop dogg and eminem also
said bad words a long time ago and still
say bad words today in fact
not long before joe rogan began making
edgy jokes on his podcast
eminem was rapping about killing gay
people
he did that for like 10 years
that was his
he dedicated like three albums to it
yet he's allowed to have his platform
even the biggest platform and he's
allowed to stay on spotify without
objection by the way all these guys are
on spotify
i don't i don't when's the last time any
uh
any uh
other artist
so i'm pulling my my music from spotify
until eminem has taken off
but they're allowed to do this because
in recent years
especially eminem you know he's begun
making his own payments on the wolf
altar
like this at the conclusion of the
performance eminem dramatically took a
knee
another payment was made
the media afterwards hailed the the move
congratulating the rapper for kneeling
to honor colin kaepernick
now you notice how they're not even
pretending that the knee thing has
anything to do with police brutality
anymore not even pretending all the
headlines are saying he was kneeling to
honor colin kaepernick
now that's why they do it
to honor a multi-millionaire nike brand
ambassador and media personality
it's a totally empty gesture and always
was of course
like everything else from the left
thus in its own way i suppose a fitting
tribute
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
well we're in for a big battle over that
supreme court vacancy and as you know
justice breyer recently renounced his
retirement handing joe biden the
opportunity to get the most liberal
person that he can find to fill the seat
well you may not know however is that
there was a lot of money money from
unnamed sources put into getting justice
briar to retire in the first place our
friends over the judicial crisis network
are raising the alarm about the role
those dark money groups are playing in
the effort to get a radical appointed to
the supreme court at the very top is a
group called arabella advisors they fund
a lot of far-left groups including
demand justice the new york post
reported that the man justice ran a
bullying campaign against justice breyer
using their considerable resources to
force him into retirement they even went
so far as to drive a mobile billboard
around the supreme court that said briar
retire it's time for a black woman
supreme court justice there's no time to
waste
and it worked now they're pouring a ton
of money into getting a radical liberal
supreme court nominee it will serve as a
rubber stamp for their unpopular
far-left agenda the judicial crisis
network is calling them out with a big
ad campaign designed to shine a light on
liberal dark money groups and their
plans to transform america you can find
out more on twitter at judicial network
or at
judicialnetwork.com
all right uh uh i i would be remiss for
mentioning it is valentine's day as well
happy valentine's day to those who
celebrate um which is everybody
begrudgingly
here's the thing about valentine's day
i'm speaking as a married man of 10
years and and also as a as a love guru
of sorts
um it it is the ultimate catch-22 for
men because on the one hand you know you
can't do nothing for valentine's day
i would i would hope that most men know
this that you don't want to fall into
the trap but you can't literally ignore
the day
even if you have a wife like i do
who says that well i don't care about
valentine's day
i would hope and maybe there's some some
some younger guys out there who just got
married and you're not as familiar
um you don't know how this works
and you might make the mistake you might
you might your wife might say i i don't
really care about valentine's day
and then so february 14th comes along
and you don't do anything because she
said she doesn't care about it
but here's the thing you make that
mistake only once in your life
so even if you have
you know wives who basically don't care
that much
you can only take that indifference so
far you can only depend on it so much
but on the other hand you can't actually
try to be sincerely romantic on
valentine's day because there's no way
to do that without seeming corny and
forced it's like
i don't know it's like um
it's like wearing the band's t-shirt to
their own concert it's too sort of on
the nose
also if you're if you aren't romantic
any other time of the year
you can't try it on valentine's day
without it being totally transparent and
if you are romantic other times then
there's no reason to go heavy on on the
valentine's day stuff
so this is what you're left with
kind of uh you can't do nothing but you
can't do too much
and that's why valentine's day is the
ultimate women's holiday really
you know a woman came up with it
because they love putting men in these
kinds of situations it's entrapment
basically that's what the whole day is
i'm just gonna hope my wife doesn't
listen to the show today and hear this
part but here's the thing everything i'm
saying right now i got a bunch of
snitches in the audience and every time
i talk about any story involving my wife
people will go on twitter did you did
you hear what matt said today
go listen to the show and they'll give
their time give her the time stamps and
everything
there are there are moles in the sweet
baby gang and i'm gonna find your people
out and ban you from the show
um all right
so uh
what's that
oh yeah i was i was told to uh that i
was given okay
you know
uh the control room they know how much i
love surprises especially holiday themed
surprises which is what i'm thinking
this is so i was given this
card i guess and told to open it
oh there's a box with it too okay
all right oh here we go
north pole pals oh it's a chocolate
walrus now see that actually is a nice
surprise i don't even know they made
those uh it's not valentine's day theme
is more of a it's more of a christmas
thing but that's that's nice that's good
like johnny the walrus
it harkens back to johnny the walrus
which is my children's book if you've
never heard me mention that before
go to johnnywalrus.com
uh
you're from your loyal producer mckenna
i'll always circle back
for you this is from uh
and there we go jen pasake there and
it's signed by everyone that's uh
very nice and
uh
thanks thanks everybody thanks for that
i i'm crying um my gratitude as you know
is all is all internal i feel a lot of
gratitude for this gift
but it's all i feel it inside i can't
express it outwardly
so but i do like the chocolate though
go to johnnywalrus.com all right um
so a couple of super bowl ads that i
want to play well we'll play just parts
of them because you know um
not worth playing the entire thing
this to me was the well we'll start with
this this is clip 8 so this is
google
put out i think they they went they
probably won the trophy los angeles they
won the trophy for the uh for for
winning the super bowl but the trophy
for wokest ad i think has to go to
google because they put out an ad
advertising their new phone i guess
which has great camera technology which
is which is fine because everybody wants
i guess the camera the cameras on the
phones are never good enough i i think
that's like the what we have now is is
probably enough it kind of it captures
the scene well enough we got to keep
improving the cameras so they put out an
ad that advertises that but
in the context of the ad they basically
accused cameras other cameras cameras
before this one of being racist so let's
i'll probably have to narrate some of
those because it's mostly visual but
let's let's play
this historically camera technology
hasn't accurately represented dark
skinned having good lighting every
single yearbook photo of mine has been
terribly shot since i was a kid i always
show up as too dark or shiny
cause if you love me you love all of me
introducing real tone
everything
there we go oh
baby give me love i think that's is that
lizzo in the background
[Music]
you know it's a problem
you know we talk about lizzo too much on
the show and i can actually identify one
of her songs i can identify her
[Music]
voice so there's the basically the ad
and a lot of then we see pictures a lot
of non-white people and they're nice
they're not oh there's lizzle there
there she is everyone deserves to be
seen as they truly are
um
so the point is that uh that previous to
this cameras were systemically racist
and you were not able to take a picture
of a non-white person all the picture
look pictures look bad
and google is fixing that now now here's
the thing
um if there's a
if if in the past cameras
you know the lighting with with the
camera technology wasn't good or
that you could just advertise that you
could you could make that point in your
ad and it would be fine
but everything has to be framed in a
racial context if it can be and it turns
out that everything can be they'll find
a way to do it
and so even this ad for a camera
is uh is is framed in a racial context
which by the way
um if there's some idea that there's
like white privilege when it comes to
cameras and and pictures
i look horrible i look like a ghost in
every picture that's ever been taken on
me i look i look dead i look like i've
been dead in the ground
for five days and every single picture
taken of me
which you might point out i look like
that in real life but but i look
i look even even worse in the pictures
so if you're white then you end up
looking kind of
more pale in pictures oftentimes
i guess if you're black oftentimes you
end up looking darker in pictures so i
think that just has to do with lighting
and you could probably solve a lot of
those problems just by positioning your
camera differently and making sure the
lighting is better
just a thought
but the creepiest ad i think was
the company formerly known as facebook
which is now meta
and uh they put out this ad for their
virtual reality their new virtual
reality feature which isn't even a
feature that's going to become this is
their vision they want uh they want the
internet to become they want the virtual
reality the metaverse to replace the
internet and here's their ad for it
let's put this up here
it's kind of hard to understand what's
happening in this ad
but this looks to be like a like you
know a chuck e cheese knockoff and
you've got those animatronic animals
and the chuck e cheese shuts down
because all the chucky cheeses are
shutting down it's kind of sad
the animatronic animals are they they
send them to a pawn shop
and kind of repurpose them in a mini
golf course that's nice now he's just
thrown to now they're going to throw him
away
because they don't need the animatronic
animals anymore
and then he's rescued
and someone sees the animatronic animal
and puts the vr headset on him
[Music]
and now he has now he is reborn he has a
new life now
in the metaverse
where nobody has any legs
you are a disembodied
half husk of a of a person in the middle
of old friends new fun
metaquest too okay i don't know exactly
what the point is in that ad is but i
think what they're trying to say if i
were to interpret it
it seems like they're saying that we as
human beings are like these useless old
outdated animatronic toys
and now we need the metaverse to be
reborn and to be given a new purpose in
life
that's not creepy at all is it no
all right let's uh move to this before
the super bowl joe biden wandered into
an interview with nbc
and a couple of uh questions were thrown
his way not very many you know he
doesn't sit down for very long
interviews these days and they keep the
questions very simple and very easy
and he still finds a way to sound
incoherent in answering them so first
he's asked about masking
and uh here's his answer to that
you were interviewed a year ago about
the super bowl and you expressed hope
that come this year that they'd be able
to fill the stands again with people
and that apparently is going to be the
case however
many of those people won't be wearing
masks despite the local law in los
angeles what is your message to people
who want desperately for this to be over
and to be able to resume the lives that
they remember
well look um
i love how people talk about personal
freedom
if you're exercising personal freedom
freedom put someone else in jeopardy
their health in jeopardy
i don't consider that being very
dealing with freedom
it's about
moving the direction you know is likely
to diminish the prospects that this
virus continues to spread
and so i
i think people should get the shots we
know the shots work
we know they work for the kind for the
the variants that are available or that
we are dealing with now
we know we have so many more tools at
our disposal to prevent death and
prevent serious illness and i i just
think they should be careful and if
they're not careful for themselves at
least think of their children think of
their you know their families
kind of hard to understand what he's
what he's even trying to say there
as he continues to fall apart more and
more each day
but think of think of the think of the
children he says think of the children
yeah well the children now as we covered
children are the only ones that have to
wear masks anymore
at least in the in the worst places in
america now if you're not in one of the
worst places in america hopefully even
your kids don't have to wear them
anymore um
but in all of the worst cities in
america children are the only ones that
have to wear it
so think about them yeah we should think
about them think about their mental and
psychological well-being
think about their developmental
well-being as well maybe maybe that's
something we should take into
consideration
the conversation continued and now
lester hall asks joe biden about the
claims of racism in the nfl and if you
thought his answer on masking was kind
of incoherent and rambling and hard to
understand well get a load of this
once again super bowl another
controversy over the nfl this about
alleged racial hiring practices do you
think the nfl because of its its broad
influence should be held to a higher
standard when it comes to issues like
this
well i think it should be held a
reasonable standard and
you know
the commissioner pointed out they
haven't lived up to what they committed
to
and lived up to
being open about hiring more minorities
to
run teams and
whether or not
you know goodell says they're going to
take a look at
what
whether they can meet the standard and
the standard was set
by you know
someone who said this is something we
should do think about it it's i think
it's
the whole idea that
a league
that is made up of so many
athletes of color as well as
so diverse
that there's not
enough
african-american qualified coaches to
quote to manage
these nfl teams it just seems to me that
it's a standard that that they'd want to
live up to i don't there's not a
requirement of law but it's a
requirement i think of some just generic
decency
some what some
did you say generic decency
genetic decency what did he say um
my favorite part of the answer was when
he said another inspiring moment from
joe biden he said the standard was set
by someone who said this is something we
should do oh well
okay well never okay well if it was set
by someone
who said this is something we should do
then
how
how can anyone object i mean is some
someone said
that we should do it so we should do it
you know i don't know if i really agree
with this standard doesn't make a lot of
sense hey listen man
this standard was set by someone
who said this is something we should do
oh well okay no i i thought the standard
was set by someone who said we shouldn't
do it in which case we shouldn't do it
because then even the person who set the
standard thinks we should but if the
person who set the standard of things we
should do it then who are we to not obey
the standard
joe biden it's always fun watching it
because
you can tell in the middle of a sentence
when he'll give up on a sentence in the
middle of it
and he'll kind of you can tell in in
that sentence you could almost you could
see kind of the the thought bubble and
read it because he starts he starts
speaking and he goes the standard was
set by someone who and then right at
that moment
in his head he's freaking out because he
doesn't know where he's going with the
sentence he and he realizes that he
doesn't know who set the standard or
what standard they're even talking about
so he just throws some words in to get
out of that sentence and bail out and
then he resets and he always resets with
a rejoinder like think about it or
listen or come on
anytime one of those phrases are used
when joe biden is speaking think about
it listen or come on it means that what
came right before that made no sense at
all and it was just his way of resetting
and trying to start over again
so it's always a lot of fun but we know
that um yeah there's a lot of racism in
the nfl i mean they they uh
uh
because nfl teams
as we've covered 60 of the league is is
made up of black athletes even though
black people only count for 13 of the
population
and if you were to narrow that down to
black men it's probably you know i don't
know five or six percent or something
um and yet they account for it for
60 percent of of the nfl of the players
in the nfl and they comprise the
majority of most positions
right and and even positions where
they were underrepresented historically
uh now even that is changing like in
quarterback i mean
many of the
the most exciting
young
talented
um quarterbacks coming into the league
now are black
so
you look at that and you think well well
it seems like
the nfl
basically their strategy of the strategy
of most teams is to put the best person
for the job into each position
now a lot of teams are very bad at
making that analysis
okay if you're a fan in cleveland or
detroit or jacksonville
uh or washington dc or philly or new
york or dallas you know that oftentimes
teams are not very good at actually
finding out who the best player is but
that is what they're trying to do
all evidence points to that
and that's how you end up with 60 of the
league is black
and yet we're told
that in the one specific area of head
coach
there are teams saying that no no i
don't even if this person it would be
would be the best coach and he would
lead us to five super bowls in a row i
don't want him because he's black
that's the theory
that's the theory of the case
is that that's what's happening that
there are teams
who are choosing to forfeit victories
and super bowls and therefore money
because they don't want to put
qualified blackhead coaches in that
position
but they'll put qualified black people
in every other position on the team
that's total nonsense
absolute nonsense
all right on abc on sunday
nancy pelosi
put the nail basically in the coffin of
the uh defund the police movement
let's listen to that
the other thing that's weighing on
people right now is rising crime uh and
there appear to be some divisions among
democrats about how to handle it your
colleague karen bass running for mayor
of los angeles is trying to increase the
police force in l.a corey bush
congresswoman from missouri is saying
it's time to defund the police he's
sticking by that you're the speaker how
do you think democrats should address
rising crime well with all the respect
in the world for court push that is not
the position of the democratic party
community safety
to protect and defend in every way is
our oath of office
and i have sympathy
we're all concerned about mistreatment
of people and that's why
uh karen bass had the justice and
policing act and we would hope to get
some of that done whether it's no knock
or joke colt or some of those issues
even if we can't get it all done but the
but
make no mistake
community safety is our responsibility
and uh
i approached one of my colleagues from
new york which richard torres a brand
new member of congress way on the left
saying that
if on the police is dead that causes a
concern with a few in our caucus but
public safety is our responsibility and
i support what karen bass is doing
and mayor adams of of new york
um it's pretty good walrus by the way
as far as walruses go
yeah don't listen to anything she said i
know i certainly wasn't
uh
what we can't let the democrats do
just like with with masking with
lockdowns and everything else
chain after all the damage has been done
change courses
you know make uh make a sharp right turn
in this case
and not that far right but just
you know
away from away from the ledge slightly
and then um and then what expect us to
say bygones be bygones all is forgiven
yeah they're they're abandoning the
defund the police movement
um
even though it's still you still people
like corey bush hanging on to it who
nancy pelosi professes to have utmost
respect for no she doesn't no one has
respect for corey bush why would you
there's nothing there's absolutely
nothing respectable about her she's a
horrible scumbag
um
but now they're gonna they're they're
getting away from it
after after years
of
paying lip service to the defunded
police movement encouraging it and
actually defunding the police and some
of these
in some of these cities
and where the police were not actively
defunded they've still been
their effect has been mitigated they've
been undermined
so the defund the police movement may
have not led to
uh it may not have successfully led to
what what these people wanted which was
to actually defund the police all across
the country there were some of that
but where they couldn't defund the
police instead they just undermined the
police
as much as they possibly could
both through rhetoric and also by
putting these soros-funded das in there
who um every time the police capture a
bad guy and send him over to the court
system the court system says oh thanks
for doing that and then just tosses him
back out the door onto the street again
and now after all it's been done for
years
um
many lives lost because of it
chaos and anarchy in our streets because
of it even more chaos in anarchy
now they want to say oh never mind we're
not going to do that change our minds
just like forcing people to wear masks
for years shutting down businesses all
never mind
the facts on the ground have changed so
we we're going to
we're going to change with them no
nothing changed
this was always a horrible idea
it was never anything but horrible it
was always going to cause profound
damage it was meant to and it did
and it's too late now to say never mind
because that damage has been done
all right i want to play this for you
also now this is another one
i feel like this in this in this episode
the people watching it on video are
experiencing some privilege because
there's been a few a few different
things that don't translate as well to
audio but i've got to play this because
it's just it's too good
um
michelle wu who's the mayor of boston
decided to do a little instagram live
session a couple of days ago
and uh
that's always risky
you know because you're live on the air
and you're you're opening yourself up to
questions
and you don't know what questions are
going to be asked
um
we do this so we have all access live
here if you become a daily wired member
you get you get access to all access
live and where we sit down and we're
live and we're just answering any
questions that come up
right
so this is what she did only a little
bit of a riskier proposition because
she's on on instagram
and she's sitting there
um i guess expecting that there'd be a
whole bunch of
softball questions
that's not how it turned out so just
let's play some of this and we'll so
here she is go ahead and play this
um
oh since she's unable to join
okay now she's sitting there
looking extremely awkward and you can
see in her eyes the panic setting in and
she's trying her best but every single
question is you're ruining the city in
the meantime i will
try to just fill this
by answering any questions anyone has
to answer any questions anyone has but
she's not answering any of the questions
who uh
[Music]
different oh happy new year yes year of
the tiger
very very cute all the other questions
are you're ruining the city you're
horrible and the mask mandates when will
you lift the mandates that's actually a
fair question she could answer that
when will you lift it we're checking
with the congresswoman's team and if
it comes down to it i will log out and
log back in unmask our kids doesn't want
to answer that
[Music]
you almost feel sorry for it almost
almost watching
this end the mandates recall her
just
every single comment
why don't you care about your people
fair question fair question
see now she's just sitting there she's
giving up
she's looking for her way out what's my
favorite thing about boston winter um
i
i
i love snow i know
here's what this is why i wanted to play
that entire thing
because she sits down
for instagram live assuming that the
internet will be nice to her and that's
mistake number one
never assume that the internet will be
nice to you especially when you are a
an incompetent tyrannical mayor who's
ruined your city
you definitely don't want to assume it
then
um
but she thinks you can get a bunch of
softball questions she doesn't and so
all the questions are why are you
ruining the city what you're doing is
horrible when will you lift the mandates
all the comments and questions are fair
but of course she doesn't want to engage
with any of those
and then at the very end she finally
gets
a softball question the kind that she
was hoping to get
which is what's your favorite thing
about winter
because by the way you know that when
this started
and it was going the wrong way
they they were scrambling on the other
side they were getting staffers on
instagram live to throw out the
softballs
and so one of the staffers they're in
the next room and they type out the
softball question what's your favorite
thing about winter mayor
and she can't even answer that even that
she can't answer it you're the mayor of
boston
and someone says what's your favorite
thing about winter um
uh do
i like the snow
even that was too hard for her
i swear the the most unimpressive people
in the country become politicians the
most unimpressive
all right one last thing let's just
throw this up on the screen this is a
tweet from gnome scheiber
who is a
labor reporter at the new york times
and you know this is my favorite genre
of tweet i love these
um
this is the made up
kids story that's supposed to have some
kind of political message so he says
me to eight-year-old what who do you
want to win the bangles or the rams
eight-year-old what difference does it
make it's not like the winner is going
to solve climate change
super bowl weekend in the scheiber
sullivan household got heavy real quick
gnome says
i you just knew of of course he
hyphenates it you knew that was going to
happen didn't you of course it's the
scheiber sullivan house
um
now
totally made-up story obviously okay no
no eight-year-old is going to respond
that way
hey you want to watch the game son who
do you think's going to win what what's
the point there's climate change
systemic racism
dad i just i just can't i just don't
care
you know it's made up but
what's the point of the made-up story
if this if this actually happened in
real life
then that would mean that noam scheiber
is a horrible father
who is psychologically tormenting his
children
to the point that his eight-year-old is
already a joyless
empty husk of a person who who who just
sits around fretting about climate
change instead of wanting to watch a
football game
so you're making up a story
where if the story is true that's the
moral of the story
you're trying to convince people that
you psychologically torment and abuse
your kids
which by the way gnome i believe that
you do so trust me i believe you
um but i still don't think that that
story is true
you know keeping your internet connected
devices updated is always a good idea
not just for consumers but for companies
as well one bug getting a lot of media
attention lately is called log 4j cyber
criminals can exploit this bug to break
into a server and steal data that's just
one of the ways we put our information
at risk on the internet every day it's a
new way and in an instant a cyber
criminal could steal what's yours
sometimes even harm your finances your
credit your reputation good thing
there's life lifelock helps detect a
wide range of identity threats like your
social security number if it's for sale
in the dark web if they detect your
information has potentially been
compromised they'll send you an alert
you have access also to a dedicated
restoration specialist if you do become
a victim so you have multiple levels of
protection
and no one can prevent all identity
theft or monitor all transactions at all
businesses but you can help protect
what's yours with lifelock by norton
join now and save up to 25 off your
first year at lifelock.com walsh that's
25 off at lifelock.com walsh for 25 off
let's get to our comment section
[Music]
all right sweet uh dailywire.com sweet
baby comments comments if you want to
leave a um
leave a video comment let's see what we
have here
um let's go to clip 11.
hey matt walsh so i just saw your video
of the teacher uh showing the reaction
of her students when she told them they
don't have to wear masks anymore i
thought it was very interesting because
i'm also a teacher in nevada
yesterday when i told my students they
don't have to wear their mask anymore i
got a very mixed reaction half of my
class was like the teacher in the video
where they were very excited and ready
to take the mask off i had kids
wanting to burn their mask basically
but then i had some students who were
had a very different reaction
a lot of them were afraid to take off
the mask because they kept asking if
corona was going to get them now because
their parents instilled this fear in
them
and then i had several girls especially
afraid to take the mask off because they
didn't want to show their face
they were too afraid to show their face
because they didn't want people to make
fun of the way that they looked this was
absolutely heartbreaking to me and it
wasn't just
one or two girls it was multiple girls
in my class who had this concern
and it just really showed me the
psychological trauma that these masks
have had on children
oh and of course sweet baby gang for
life
yeah i thought about that thanks for
that story i mean it's
uh it is
horrifying and really sad but i thought
about that when we played the clip on
friday that she's referencing
of the kids in elementary school they're
told the mask mandate is going to be
lifted and they are celebrating joyously
um and i said even that video it's it's
great to see
that the kids are happy and that they
don't have to wear the stupid masks
anymore so it's a good video in that
sense
but it's also a terrible video because
it shows what these kids have been
subjected to for two years um
that now they're so excited to be able
to take the masks off
but then i also thought to myself you
know an even worse version of that video
is one where the kids are told hey you
can take the masks off and um they don't
care or even they're they don't want to
they're afraid
to take it off which
based on that comment and i'm sure there
are many more um
uh you know many many other teachers and
parents who could who have similar
stories
a lot of kids are in that boat
there are you know it's bad enough to
have kids who
have have been forced to wear the mask
for two years and they and they've been
resisting it this entire time and
they've hated it this entire time and
they're desperate to take the damn thing
off
that's that's bad
the even worse scenario would be the
kids who have been wearing it this
entire time and don't hate it anymore
and actually are desperate to keep it on
because they've been convinced
by the conditioning the brainwashing
that if they take the mask off and walk
outside their house they're going to die
and for those kids
i have to believe that the damage can be
undone that that it could be repaired
some way
but it's not going to be an easy fix
you know when you condition young
children to be afraid of
fresh air
to see everyone around them as physical
threats to them as as biological
weapons you know walking biological
weapons
when you condition kids to see the world
that way and see each other that way
um
it that's not it's not it's not an easy
thing to reverse
put it that way all right one more
comment
uh so let's play clip 12.
hey matt huge fan of the show long time
listener um however i do remember the
day i was listening and you made that
joke about us being sweet babies and you
being sweet daddy and i remember
thinking to myself
wow i hope this joke doesn't stick
and maybe this will get me banned from
the show but you know what i don't care
because every day we have to listen to
videos of people calling you daddy and
that's your fault you have made this bed
sir and now we all have to lie in it so
yes
the sweet baby gang does truly seem to
be for life
first of all how dare you say sweet baby
gang for life
after
that propaganda
and victim blaming
victim blaming me
i i might have said the sweet daddy
walsh thing
okay i might have said it but everybody
should know you don't you don't follow
every order given to you even in a cult
so that's not just fault
listen just following orders is never an
acceptable moral excuse
there are times when you should know
better
and and this was one of those times so i
i take zero responsibility for it
or for anything else in my life
well thanks for the comment uh you're
banned from the show
all right a couple written comments here
um
kl says matt i like you but your subway
slander has gotten out of hand please
ban me from the show okay there's a lot
of it's a lot of people getting banned
you're getting banned also
uh yeah we this is a conversation we had
on twitter yesterday about the the best
sandwich chains in america and the
official ranking by the way and this is
important for you to know this
this is of sandwich chains so i don't
want anyone i don't need any hipster to
tell me oh but my local deli is better
i'm not talking about your local deli
i'm talking about sandwich chains
and the ranking goes like this
number one is jersey mike's number two
is firehouse subs number three is pot
bellies
number four
uh and this number four this is usually
where we would put quiznos but quiznos
basically doesn't exist anymore our
r.i.p and so instead we're putting jimmy
john's there number five is arby's
number six is like a
an old uh lukewarm
egg salad sandwich from the gas station
and then number seven
is subway way at the bottom because
subway the only advantage that subway
has and the only reason it's that it
exists and that it's as powerful as it
is
is that the stuff is really cheap
but it's not even as cheap as it used to
be i mean i can remember going back back
in the day you go into subway and
remember five dollar foot long it wasn't
all that long ago now that now they're
trying to get like eight or nine dollars
out of you
for a foot long sub
with stale bread
disgusting spoiled meat
wilted lettuce and and and
you know
pickles and olives that have been
sitting there for days
literally any sandwich chain is better
than subway
and on top of that they all smell bad
every
that's the worst thing about it
is you um
you walk into subway and it has this
weird like
it's hard to even put your finger on it
exactly what it is and if you did find
out what it is i'm not sure you'd want
to put your finger on it but it's this
weird kind of
almost like disturbing unsettling smell
and you can never quite figure out what
it is exactly
and i've heard people tell me oh it's
the bread baking no i know what bread
baking smells like
there's there's nothing better there's
no better smell in the world than fresh
baked bread that is not the subway smell
i don't know what it is but all they all
smell bad they taste bad they're
terrible
the customer service is always bad
everywhere every single subway
but i'll still eat it
um what else do we got
uh let's see there's one other here this
is from frederick says it's funny when
the gender fluids say i use they them
pronouns but actually they don't use
them at all
no they use i me pronouns like everybody
else but everybody everyone else has to
use they them for them so to be accurate
it should be i want everybody to use
they them pronouns for me and that does
have a different ring to it it sounds a
lot more demanding if you ask me
that's a very good point and it speaks
to what i talk about all the time with
the pronouns which is someone is
assigning words to you that you have to
use they are telling you
how you have to perceive them and how
you have to speak about them when
they're not even present because most of
the time most of the time when you're
using a pronoun about somebody it's
because they're not there you know
you're not you're not going to point to
a guy and say him usually if he's
sitting right there you're just going to
refer to him by his name
um so that is is already a big problem
and that's just not how language works
doesn't work that way
but actually it's worse than even you
have made it out to be because actually
if they them is their pronoun allegedly
then
the pronouns they should be using in
reference to themselves when they're
speaking
should be we us
if we're supposed to talk about them as
if they're multiple people
then they should be doing the same but
of course nobody does that because you'd
sound like a lunatic you'd sound like a
schizophrenic lunatic if you did that if
you walked around and referred to
yourself as we and us
um
nobody would take you seriously they
would assume that you're insane exactly
so when they talk about themselves they
use a
a singular they talk about themselves as
if they're a single person i and me
but when we refer to them we have to
pretend that they're multiple people
again insane and no one should have to
do it and no one should ever play along
with any of this
the opening weekend of our first
original production shut-in was a major
success not only did the did our
premiere reach over half a million views
but the reviews are in and shut in has a
critic score of a hundred percent
there's a shocker and an audience score
of 98 percent of ron tomatoes only a
shocker because you figured the critics
would not be able to help themselves but
give it a negative review uh but uh you
know everyone seems to agree it's a good
movie imdb is eight out of ten that's
huge also because making a film
let alone a good one is never easy but
we did it we produced a film and it's
really freaking good that's why if you
missed it i implore you to head to
dailywire.com subscribe and get a
membership today the film is now
exclusively streaming for daily wire
members and if you're not a member by
now then you're missing out this might
be our first original production but it
will not be our last we also released
the new trailer for hyperions the
anti-superhero movie starring carrie um
i don't even know how to pronounce it's
the princess bride guy how do you
pronounce his last name you louis
ooze
ill wes ill way anyway comes out in a
few weeks and tear on the prairie our
new western starring the amazing
uncancelable gina carano i can pronounce
that she's coming that's coming out this
summer as well for those of you who
don't know this weekend was the one year
anniversary of gina getting fired from
disney and us announcing our movie deal
with her so we're very excited to make
good on that promise and bring gina's
awesome movie to you we're creating more
and more great entertainment without a
leftist agenda and it's all thanks to
our daily wire members so head to
dailywire.com subscribe today so you can
watch shut in hyperions and gina's new
movie out this summer
you know as my status within the lgbtq
plus community continues to grow so does
the cultural importance of my
best-selling lgbtq plus children's book
johnny the walrus this is why i was
invited to dr phil to discuss these most
important issues with experts who could
not even tell me what a woman was if you
haven't seen it yet i highly recommend
you check it out even more importantly
if you haven't picked up a copy of my
best-selling children's book you should
do so immediately it sold out in 48
hours when it was released but don't
worry more copies are on the way reserve
johnny the walrus
now on amazon or go to
johnnythewalrus.com now let's get to our
daily cancellation
[Music]
there was a time when cnn host van jones
could have been considered one of the
nuttiest and most radical leftists in
america but these days when the cable
news landscape features luminaries like
joy reid
jones often gets lost in the progressive
shuffle unfortunately he still has his
moments no doubt like when he wepts for
tears of joy after cnn declared joe
biden the winner of the 2020 election
declaring that somehow it's uh it's
easier to be a parent and easier to be a
dad now with trump out of office
but moments like that have been fewer
and farther between for van even more
troubling there have actually been
occasions in recent years where he said
things that seem damn near lucid like
teetering dangerously close to the edge
of sanity
this is a real problem for his brand
which may explain the latest news
speaking of being a parent van jones has
announced that he welcomed a new baby
into the world this month um his third
child after his first two that he had
with his ex-wife who he divorced back in
2018.
but he's trying something a little bit
different for the third installment in a
statement to people magazine van said
after the coveted lockdown i got clear
that i wanted another kid i discovered
that my friend noemi also wanted a baby
so we decided to join forces and become
conscious co-parents it's a concept that
i hope more people will explore and
consider this month we welcome to earth
a baby girl whom we will raise as
co-parenting partners
this is a special time for our families
i feel grateful joyful and blessed as we
create a safe and loving environment for
this blessed young soul i respectfully
ask for privacy thank you for all the
love and support
yes he asks for privacy
because when you want privacy you send a
statement to people magazine
everyone knows that i personally send
people magazine my personal itinerary
every single day with a point-by-point
explanation of everything i'll do and
everywhere i'll be along with a note
that i just want privacy
and then they just they email me back
every day saying who are you exactly
more to the point
van jones said that um he was bored
during the cove lockdowns and he decided
he wanted another kid
unfortunately he isn't married to a
woman at the moment but no matter he
decides to team up with a platonic
friend and have a child as conscious
co-parents
and more people should explore and
consider this option he says
now respecting his request i did explore
the option myself and i was able to
conclude my exploration after about 12
seconds
because that's how long it takes to
analyze and consider shallow shallow
vapid like this
you notice how increasingly the word
conscious
is being used as a stand-in for
self-centered
first gwyneth paltrow introduced us to
conscious uncoupling otherwise known as
divorce
she and her husband explained that they
wanted to end their relationship so they
could focus on themselves more
the decision was conscious yes as all
decisions are
but their conscious minds were focused
on themselves
and their own perceived needs and
desires rather than on their children or
even on each other
it was a selfish uncoupling
and now we have conscious co-parenting
or selfish co-parenting
now how does this differ from
the co-parenting done by
a married mother and father
i'm married to my wife and we are very
conscious of our children and of the
fact that we are parents
we went into parenthood consciously
we've been conscious this whole time
i mean almost literally in fact we've
been we've been conscious much more than
we'd like to be such as today when our
boys woke us up at 4 30 in the morning
because they decided it was an hour and
a half that an hour and a half before
dawn was a good time to get out of bed
and play with their spiderman toys
i was very conscious in that moment
or half conscious anyway
so what does the conscious qualifier
mean here
well again substitute self-centered and
it makes more sense
van jones has embarked on a journey of
self-centered parenting
he is conscious but mostly conscious of
himself
he wanted another kid but he didn't want
to get married he didn't want to change
his lifestyle that much
and he wasn't really worried about what
environment would be best for the child
so he decided to enter into this round
of parenting as if it was a business
arrangement
that's what he wanted to do that's what
was best for him
self-centered parenting
he's hardly the first self-centered
parent he's no trailblazer in that
regard but he is the guy who came up
with a name for it
and that's uh that's the other important
point about this
conscious co-parenting is supposed to be
the evolved progressive version of
traditional parenting
as always though
the evolved progressive version of an
old institution is exactly the same as
the old institution but minus everything
that made it special beautiful and good
we live in a culture where everything is
being sanitized hollowed out emptied out
stripped of all of its defining and
unique features
going from regular parenting to
conscious co-parenting it's like melting
down michelangelo's pieta sculpture and
replacing it with a with some kind of
like plastic reconstruction now from a
distance it might look similar to what
existed before
but a closer inspection reveals that all
of the best things about it
have been destroyed
and yet somehow it's supposed to be an
improvement
platonic co-parenting is from a distance
on a day-to-day basis
similar to the traditional mode of
parenting in that two adults are taking
care of a child
the difference and it's a very big
difference
is that the love and devotion between
the parents
has been removed from the equation
this is quite a problem because that
love and devotion and that commitment
is the very thing that holds the whole
unit together
it's the foundation upon which the
family is built it's the shelter that
the children can take refuge under it's
their wall of protection
it's the most important lesson they'll
ever learn
as as kids kids need to see what a
loving relationship between a man and
woman looks like
they need to live with that example
every day
and on top of all this marriages are all
kind of you know weird in their own way
sometimes challenging hopefully often
joyful funny fun difficult intense
complicated but also simple
there are many things all at once
and that's what gives each family unit
its own distinct sort of strangeness
marriage is not only the essential
ingredient of the family it's also the
spice
now as i said it's everything that makes
the whole family experience special and
good and distinct
the leftist vision is to strip that away
sanitize it
and replace it with something bland and
flimsy and boring and useless
platonic co-parenting
you can hardly utter the phrase without
falling asleep
that's how dull and sad it is
and that's why van jones is today we
must say cancelled
that'll do it for today thanks for
watching thanks for listening have a
great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens production manager pavel
voldowski the show is edited by robbie
dantzler our audio is mixed by mike
coromina hair and makeup is done by
cherokee heart and our production
coordinator is mckenna waters matt wall
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2022
john bickley here daily wire
editor-in-chief wake up every morning
with our show morning wire where we
bring you all the news that you need to
know in 15 minutes or less
join me and my co-host georgia hal for
daily coverage of all the biggest
stories on morning wire